of all the characters i've ever done
theories about perhaps none is more
hashtag relatable
than dib from invader zim my name is
dib membrane i'm 12 years old
and i'm all that stands between sim and
the annihilation
of our this poor kid's a theorist after
my own heart oh sure he sounds like a
raving lunatic but he's proven time and
time again to be right about some of the
universe's greatest mysteries
including the existence of aliens am i
the only one here who sees the alien
sitting in class
right there you're crazy what about his
horrible green head
it's a skin condition plus he wears a
cool jacket you all know how i feel
about cool jackets
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that's basically me pulling a
dib for like 15 minutes every week you
see
actual proof that all the things i've
been saying are actually
right as you might be able to tell
today's theory is all about everyone's
favorite invader
zim i am zim i am zim i am
i am true after the original netflix
movie
enter the floor piss came out in 2019 i
wanted to do a zim theory but nothing i
thought of at the time worked out
and yet there was something there
something that stuck with me in the back
of my mind like
like some kind of small insane robot
but then here at the top of the ear it
all finally clicked it clicked
after re-watching the series again i
think there's been a secret hiding in
invader zim from the very beginning
a secret that turns the show's entire
premise on its head a
secret that unlike most of our theories
i think is actually
intentional by the creators of this show
today i'm gonna prove to you that
professor
membrane earth's most renowned human
person scientist and father of the proto
matpat known as dib
is actually an alien just like zim
himself
and now the man without whom this world
falls into chaos
and the inventor of super toast
professor membrane
now admittedly i'm a bit late to the
party vader zim's been off the air
longer than i've been making film
theories so let's just get quickly
caught up with the story so we're all on
the same page
many years ago the alien named zim was
put in charge of operation
impending doom a plan by the urcan race
to invade many planets
let us reign some doom down upon the
filthy heads of our
doomed enemies
bad news is zim's enthusiasm was so
overwhelming that he launched his attack
on the home planet
as a result zim gets banished to the
planet food courtia where he's set to
serve fast food for the rest of his life
however
when he hears of operation impending
doom 2 he decides to quit being banished
so he can lead another invasion the
erkin society is led by their tallest
members known as the almighty tallest
when the tallest
see that zim has returned they decide to
really get him out of their hair
and send him to an unknown planet later
revealed as
earth when he arrives at earth zim
attempts to blend into society through
some
unconvincing means while most people
accept that his green coloring is just a
skin condition one of zim's classmates
dib sees right through the disguise dib
already obsessed with the paranormal
loses his mind trying to prove zim's
true identity throughout the entire
process though his own father
professor membrane stands in staunch
opposition to his son's efforts
so i find you here son you know not to
use my tools for your
parasites as one of the world's leading
scientists professor membrane claims to
have revolutionized every field of
scientific study and he takes a hard
stance against the existence of the
paranormal
membrane constantly tells dib that his
fake science is inferior to membranes
real science despite
sometimes being presented with
overwhelming evidence of the existence
of aliens
there are no aliens you've been watching
those transmissions since you were a
baby with an enormous head
it's time to move on son and this is our
first clue that professor membrane isn't
all that he seems despite having a
clearly scientific mind he
absolutely refuses to acknowledge any
evidence of alien life
beyond the typical things that other
earthlings write off like zim's
appearance
membrane is confronted directly with
aliens in alien technology multiple
times throughout the series but
repeatedly chooses to ignore it
in the episode bloaty's pizza hog which
was fnaf before fnaf
existed dib and his sister gaz call
membrane from a working
urcan spaceship no reaction later in the
invader zim movie enter the florpis he's
confronted with a garage of evidence but
again declares it all
fake as a man of science i need proof
and i just haven't seen proof
how do you need more proof than this
everything i've collected for my
countless battles with zim
i wish just once you'd have my back
wishing isn't very scientific son and it
only gets worse considering by the end
of that movie
membrane is abducted by zim taken to
space
jail and surrounded by actual aliens
rather than considering all the
possibilities of such a wild discovery
membrane instead acts like the whole
thing was just a hallucination
well that was very convincing because
it's
real dad he even admits confusion over
the existence of his alien doppelganger
clem brain i'm
very confused right now but continues to
deny the existence of aliens often going
on tv to make such a claim
even at the expense of his own son what
about that glowing thing
look at it that's no human glow possibly
a weather balloon
or swamp gas it's almost like he's
trying to keep the public in the dark
about aliens for some reason
now one obvious reason for this could be
that membrane himself
is an alien first let's look at his
character design shall we he wears a
face covering lab coat with goggles
at all times and i do mean all times
he's been dressed this way since he was
a child
i asked santa to bring me 12 cases of
uranium-238
it's very similar and look to what we
see members of the irkan race wearing on
the mother ship
tall necked collars to hide the bottom
of their faces and the goggles would
presumably hide his alien eyes
it's also worth noting that membrane
happens to have the exact same hairstyle
as zim's human disguise which the wiki
refers to as a shark fin haircut
coincidence maybe but perhaps most
tellingly of all is membrane's lack
of ears the show makes no small deal
about zim's lack of ears
identifying him as an alien and he's got
no ears is that part of your skin
condition zim no ears now look at
membrane
no ears maybe they're covered by the
goggle strap but that would just make it
really impossible to hear anything and
also be super uncomfortable
no it is much more likely that his ears
are just gone and here's the kicker the
one thing that goggles can't hide
is membrane's lack of a nose nothing is
there on his face
and we know for a fact that something is
drawn in the other characters
all the other characters on the show
have noses except for
you guessed it zim the alien even the
strange way membrane chooses to
emphasize words feels very much like the
speech patterns of our favorite
alien zim it has been one day already
and the cure for pig mouth still eludes
me ms bitters i have a mighty lead
to use the restroom once again now let's
talk about advanced technology the earth
of invader zim seems to be set in the
early 2000s based on the gravestones
that we see in the series and yet human
society appears to have much more
advanced technology than you would
expect from that
era why well it seems to be coming from
membrane labs
membrane labs who wants a better
everything throughout the show we're
shown that professor membrane is a
combination of steve jobs elon musk and
nikola tesla revolutionizing almost
every facet of technology on earth and
setting trends while he does it
the whole ignorant world watches as
professor membrane prepares to make the
greatest announcement he's made
since last week so is he just smart or
is he actually an
alien we see that urkin technology far
exceeds that of modern earth even an
idiot like zim can create a time travel
device with a lab down in his basement
and he shows a clear disdain for earth
or can technology play with more
advanced toys and we see that much of
membranes technology is significantly
more advanced than the average earth
tech even things like his kitchen
appliances are either sentient or
potentially deadly be sure to take them
out of the can
or the explosion will destroy all human
life now
advanced technology alone doesn't
necessarily mean that he's an alien the
fact that his technology
looks a lot like urkin technology though
does
a lot of membranes tech has weird vacuum
tubes bulbous shapes and purple coloring
all the signatures of
alien and specifically urkin tech in one
night membrane is able to add an entire
wing onto his lab to research gaza's pig
girl mutation which is something that we
know
urkin technology does and when it's done
it happens to look a lot like the inside
of an urchin base but it all goes beyond
mere aesthetics here
membrane labs tech is canonically urkin
in one episode dib is taken captive by
zim to escape dib needs to hack zim's
computer
and then this happens i only hope the
erkins just happened to use the same
operating system as me
yes that's right the erkins used the
same operating system as
membrane os his father's computer system
how could the membrane operating system
interface match perfectly with urkin
tech
unless membrane himself knew about
urchin tech in the first place heck how
could dibbett found any operating system
that could interface with alien
technology unless there was
already aliens on planet earth that just
leaves us with one question why would
membrane be here if he was
indeed an alien after all the erkins
only sent zim to earth's location to get
rid of him in the pilot episode we see a
post-it note on their board where earth
happened to be
so they must have had an idea that
something was out there but they never
got any hard evidence that it actually
existed
it seems to me like they've sent someone
to earth before and i don't think it was
on a mission of invasion
and they never heard a report back one
thing that we haven't fully explored yet
is that urcan society
runs on height two taller urchins are in
leadership positions
and everyone else is much much shorter
you'd think that there'd be
a bit more variability in the urchin
race but there really isn't
right now you just have two that are
really tall and everyone else who is
just
really short there aren't any in the
middle this seems to imply that the
tallest actively
cull out other tall urchin to make sure
they stay in power
now professor membrane is quite tall
maybe even taller than the tallest it's
possible that the tallest in order to
retain their rule sent membrane out to
earth to get rid of him
just like they did to zim only membrane
was smart enough to know what was going
on
so rather than destroy earth or call
back to the mighty tallest
membrane decided to conquer and rule the
planet for himself and honestly this is
exactly what he does
once you understand that membrane is an
alien invader things start to make a lot
more sense
in this universe humanity is kept stupid
fat and helpless by the massive
corporations
which are all owned by membrane his
technology is
ever present throughout earth from the
skiffs that they use to transport
captured children in school to the wrist
devices worn by everyone on earth even
his commercials allude to a dark future
where the technology
turns on everyone there may come a time
when we
at membrane labs stop making the world
more
amazing that time is not now where zim
doesn't understand an invasion to be
anything but reckless destruction
membrane truly invaded and conquered
earth for himself
the new membrane harnesses that
childhood g tomorrow
children will hold hands encircling the
planet inner peace unlike any of the
world
has ever known those mem bracelets by
the way have a weird added feature for a
guy who doesn't acknowledge
life on other planets son the mem
bracelet is just for running apps and
world peace
but theoretically one could use it to
create a galactic stargate of sorts yes
it's certainly unusual unless of course
it's a device used to show your final
control
over all the children of earth no wonder
he was so excited for peace day it
showed his final
and complete dominance over the planet
tomorrow is peace day
and nobody is as excited for the big
celebration as i am
i am not scientifically possible
so professor membrane could very well be
an alien that successfully conquered the
planet but
that brings up the cruelest twist of
them all dib dib is funny throughout the
show
everyone and i do mean everyone from
aliens to demons comment
on his head who's that large-headed kid
i don't know
but his head is large did you conjure a
big head demon to give you a big head
man that is a really big
and not only is his head abnormally
large but it's shaped similarly
to zims we also hear talk of zim's
inhuman organs and the fact that gaz
also has those same organs bald my
squeely spooch
squiggly spooch did you hear that gas
that's no human organ humans don't have
squealy spooches
i've got a squiddly spooch oh sure this
could just be gaz being sarcastic
or it could be that gazz knows and is
comfortable with her alien origins
and her alien body parts maybe this
explains why she's membrane's favorite
child
we even have this one-off line from dib
early on in the series that never really
goes anywhere
and is never fully explained i have
vague memories being taken on board of
an alien
as ship's baby but i'm not sure when i
think they were doing tests trying to
create some kind of genius super baby
perhaps
it all fits with this final little
detail you see theorists
membranes children have no canonical
mother she doesn't appear in any
pictures she's not mentioned once by any
character in the show movie or comics no
one questions her absence
this has led some fans to conclude that
dib and gaz are clones of professor
membrane or at least were artificially
created from his genetic material
and that is not just a theory eric
trueheart one of the main writers of
invader zim has said that dib
in a future episode had the show not
gotten cancelled would have gone on a
quest to find out why his life was so
horrible only to find out that he was a
clone
of his father and i think you can see
where this is going
dib is obsessed with his quest to prove
that
zim is an alien he wants to expose the
world to the fact that aliens exist and
that in fact
one is living amongst them undetected
but the cruelest irony of all
is that he himself is an alien he is an
alien clone of his alien father
throughout the entirety of this show's
tragically short run
he's trying to expose everyone else to
the truth without once realizing
the truth for himself but hey that's
just a theory a film theory
and surely i can't be the only one
coping with
um well everything by shopping online
right nothing like a bit of retail
therapy
currently my mission is to find out how
many oversized plushies it takes to fill
the void in my heart
it's uh definitely more than six well
with today's sponsor honey you can rest
assured stephanie that your husband
won't sink your child's college fund
into collecting
squish mallows probably that's because
honey saves you money when you shop
online
it's a free browser extension that
scours the internet for promo codes and
automatically tests them when you're
checking out here's how it works it is
super easy you download honey with two
simple clicks
then when you're checking out at any of
honey's 30 000 plus supported websites
the extension alerts you to coupons that
it's found online
click apply coupons and boom instant
savings
money that remains in your pocket or i
suppose more accurately in your digital
bank account
in all seriousness with this being the
start of a new year we've been doing a
lot of work trying to get organized i'm
talking about shelves
folders binders more shelves and honey
has really come in
clutch for online shopping at the depots
that's right both home
and office honey has made it really fast
and easy to save money on the things
that we need and that's why we've been
so happy to partner with them for this
episode and
for the past couple of years so join
honey for free today by going to
joinhoney.com
film theorists or because film theorist
is really long and hard to spell just
click the link in the top line of this
description that's it that's all you
need to do and from there you're two
clicks away from saving money
the honey community is all about saving
money on all the products that you're
buying anyway so not using
honey is just stupid and us theorists
aren't stupid we're a little bit over
dramatic sometimes sometimes we're a bit
of conspiracy theorists but there's one
thing that we're not and that's stupid
go get that 16-inch gur plushie that
you've been eyeing since the beginning
of this episode you deserve it until
next time i'll see you next week